batta
c'est
moi
un classique si la
voie à quoi tu es du chambon
au nom s'appuie là dedans non
pour les eric
je voulais essayer ce jeu sort non non
non j'ai soeur écouter les sons moi mais
je vous tiens pas je ne vous dis pas que
je sois
belle et tais toi t'en fais pas
attention
[Applaudissements]
ça vous dérange pas je suis un gamin de
la main sur moi mais c'est un put c'est
crade et où faut bien qu'ils nettoient
un peu attendait le poids tant que je
suis là bah ouais mais bon c'est pas de
ma faute si vous êtes à l'intérieur même
ton et où tu vas toi ou je te parles tu
bats toi je vais te défoncer la tête en
deux secondes tu as compris pourquoi
faire donc oui mais je tenais à vegas
dyotte de las vegas des gens de la spse
de colère enfin qui dégage dégage que
dix connards de connaître
une chute dans away mais ça pue c'est
pas de ma peau malade se met à la faute
de conner je devais ajoute défonce la
tête tu vois on va faire aller est un
tabou je te dis dégage toi et moi tu ne
connais pas
mais moi non plus d'ailleurs
mais non en fait mon match il a toujours
échappé je suis
je suis désolé mais ça pue à l'intérieur
c'est qu'il n'y aurait pas d'autres à
nettoyer avant ça y est c est nettoyée à
côté des choses on se connait en plus tu
es chez toi
[Musique]